[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de j -p
aujourd'hui nous sommes en visite nous
sommes à la guinguette un restaurant
récemment ouvert à versailles tout près
du château qui gentiment nous accueille
pour recevoir une invitée de choix
une récente yvelinoise qui nous fait
plaisir de venir nous voir je parle de
julie andrieu je lis bonjour jean
véronique comment ça va ça va très bien
mais forcément bien ici à verso et on
est bien ouais merci d'être là vous êtes
là parce que vous sortez un nouveau
livre qui s'appelle a comme astuce c'est
ça la suite c'est mon abécédaire de la
cuisine julie andrieu voilà alors au cas
où sort échappé à quelques personnes
vous êtes journaliste culinaire on peut
dire ça merci animatrice d'émissions
voilà et auteure et productrice des
émissions productrice des émissions
voilà oui vous avez écrit pas mal de
livres ans au oui je les compte plus
mais il doit y en avoir une bonne
vingtaine bonne vingtaine donc voilà
c'est le petit dernier tout frais qui
vient de sortir comment on passe de la
photographie à la cuisine en deux mots
sans faire des photos de cuisine
d'ailleurs sans faire des photos alors
en deux mots et bien je ne suis pas du
tout n'est dans la marmite mois par an à
ce que la photo un deal soir non non moi
je suis issu d'une famille monoparentale
j'ai été élevé par ma maman qui était
comédienne nicole courcel pour la
génération qui pourrait la reconnaître
et elle ne s'intéressait pas du tout à
la cuisine d'accord elle considérait que
la cuisine était plutôt le symbole d'un
asservissement ménages et c'est cette
génération de femmes qui avaient lutté
monsieur voir sortir des cuisines et on
les comprend et on les remercie
d'ailleurs c'est aujourd'hui c'est plus
un combat à mener les hommes y entre
volontiers tant mieux mais à l'époque ça
avait du sens et est donc pour ma maman
la cuisine ça ne raisonnait pas beaucoup
et néanmoins à l'âge de 20 ans à peu
près 18 ans peut-être j'ai commencé à
avoir envie de cuisiner de mes propres
ailes parce que je trouvais que c'était
important quand même d'abord c'est un
plaisir déjà j'ai toujours aimé recevoir
j'ai aimé recevoir j'étais très
fédératrice et toujours une bande de
copines que j'ai toujours aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs 40 ans plus tard et puis bon
voilà je vais les recevoir mais je peux
pas les recevants avec des nems surgelés
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours et j'ai
découvert qu'en faisant deux trois trucs
ça me plaisait beaucoup
je me suis très gourmande les comme
beaucoup d'autres et c'est pas pour
autant moi je vous dis je n'étais pas un
langage que je les chrysalides mais
néanmois j'ai développé l'envi de faire
par moi-même et puis très vite je me
suis rendu compte que c'était plus que
ça c'est vraiment devenu une passion
comme on peu se découvre une passion
pour le tennis ou le piano j'adorais ça
j'allais au marché choisissez mes
produits et j'apprenais vraiment
justement à un nouveau langage
culinaires et puis c'était important
pour une adolescente rarement bien dans
sa peau les adolescents quand même de
maîtriser son corps aussi de savoir ce
qu'on ingère mois ont plutôt que des
produits industriels donc tout ça a
commencé à se façonner un peu dans mon
esprit et c'est vrai que moi j'avais la
passion pour la photo j'avais une
passion pour la photo qui a priori
devait devenir mon métier photo de
reportage donc rien à voir avec la
cuisine mais j'ai quand même trouvé des
ponts parce que finalement grâce à la
cuisine je peux voyager j'ai pu beaucoup
voyagé et puis j'ai rencontré un
photographe avec lequel j'ai vécu
quelques années kima qui m'a laissé
entendre que finalement j'avais une
image peut-être un peu surfaite et un
peu idéalisée de ce métier moi je
voulais un grand reporter comme un
robert capa commun comme un cartier
bresson commun salgado aujourd'hui bon
il m'a dit d'accord mais il y en a pas
beaucoup quand même des mecs qui
émergent qui ont ce talent là d'abord
encore fallait-il avoir c'est le talon
et puis le courage de sacrifier sa vie
privée lui il avait probablement envie
de le garder auprès de lui et donc petit
à petit il à détricoter ce que je
pensais être une passion et puis à
l'époque c'était la photo argentique qui
a précédé le numérique donc je faisais
mes développement mais tirage voilà
c'était tout un rituel qui m'obsédait
que je faisais quasiment que ça aide
d'une obsession à l'autre je suis passé
à la cuisine et voilà cherchons un petit
peu comment m'exprimer exister et puis
aussi c'est un lien vers l'extérieur
photo comme la cuisine enfin on cherche
toujours un moyen de de créer un de cgi
mais voilà qui est aussi comme moi
j'étais un enfant assez timide parfois
aussi d'avoir une possibilité de se
retrancher la cuisine c'était parfait
parce qu'à la fois jeu comme on l'a dit
on fédère et en même temps on a la
possibilité de rentrer en coulisses qui
seraient les cuisines quand tout d'un
coup la vie sociale devient peut-être un
petit peu trop oppressante donc moi
j'aimais bien ces deux pôles 1 et puis
comme je suis né justement dans ce
sérail non pas de la cuisine mais
l'audiovisuel naturellement je me suis
dit j'aime la cuisine
pourquoi ne pas faire une émission de
cuisine voilà c'est parti d'abord avec
un livre qui avec une émission mais à
une époque où l'accusé n'était pas du
tout à la mode mais non pas du tout non
alors c'est à la fois un avantage et un
inconvénient parce qu'il y avait de la
place normalement personne dans ce
créneau mais en même temps tout le monde
m'a regardé comme un martien ouais bon
ben écoutez vous en êtes arrivés là et
c'est une belle histoire bravo et
aujourd'hui donc il se livre à comme
astuce alors moi j'ai le livre d'avant
all my best 300 recettes que j'ai adoré
et je ne prétends que celui-là il est
pas en plus s'il l'est il complète
non mais franchement et qu'est ce qui
vous est donné des idées clés donné quoi
pocket donné l'idée d'écrire ce livre
bon il ya 90 recettes mais il ya surtout
900 vas-tu seul absent que c'est quand
même ça l'a bien sûr d'ailleurs le titre
lundi que c'est râlant les deux bouquins
voilà de délivrer un livre de cuisine
qui soit une sorte de couteau suisse de
la cuisine dont on peut se servir un peu
pour pour tous les jours toutes les
recettes qu'on peut aussi lire comme un
livre de chevet en partant de a jusqu'à
z parce que quand on aime un peu la
cuisine même sans être un vrai pro on
pioche des astuces comme ça dont on peut
se balade entre peut servir
régulièrement l'idée c'était surtout de
simplifier la vie des gens qui te voilà
de gagner en liberté de décomplexer
peut-être aussi de montrer que oui de
dire qu'il n'ya pas seulement la recette
cette formule magique de la recette dont
on attend tous et qui souvent foire
quand même il faut bien le dire parce
que l'on sait jamais pourquoi on sait
jamais pourquoi ces frais là j'essaye
d'expliquer le pourquoi des choses c'est
vrai parce que souvent on sait comment
ou en tout cas on nous enseigne comment
met on sait pas pourquoi et promettre
une pincée de sel dans les blancs
pourquoi faut laisser reposer la pâte à
crêpes bon on applique la recette et
puis maintenant on se dit tiens c'est
bizarre ça marche ça marche pas bon là
j'essaye d'aller un peu au delà sans
être non plus dans une approche trop
scientifique mais il ya quand même un
peu de chance bah oui c'est pas mal
quand même parce qu'on comprend le
pourquoi du comment et flemme ou pas
flemme on le fait et on est sûr que ça
que ça va réussir alors moi je pense
vous parler d eux par exemple les oeufs
à la coque c'est quand même incroyable
de ne pas être fichu de faire des à la
coop correct par exemple à mon âge je
faisais bien voilà maintenant j'ai
compris et enfin il ya plein de trucs
comme ça plein de trucs la côte de boeuf
par exemple moi là qu'ils doivent
systématiquement je trouvais qu'elle
était trop cuites à l'extérieur et trop
bleu à l'intérieur j'ai compris en
discutant avec des bouchées parce que je
vais voir aussi des fournisseurs et
notamment garrigue est ici à versailles
qui m'a donné quelques astuces
qui vend des fruits et légumes au marché
il m'a dit mais non tu as côte de boeuf
tu la sors évidemment à l'avant sur les
capteurs comment faire qu'à la viande
c'est génial non pas tant la viande en
rendant qu'il attendait des astuces pour
les fruits et légumes évidemment et il
me disait tu sors ta viande tu la mets
au four à 60° tu la laisses une bonne
demi heure et après clac clac tu l'as
marck mais juste avant de servir ce qui
est génial c'est quand j'ai une bonne
demi heure ça peut être 40 minutes on
est plus à cinq minutes près donc ça
déstresse effectivement et puis surtout
on peut recevoir ses copains les appelle
donc ses sont les astuces qui a priori
améliore quand même la qualité des plats
mais qui surtout facilite la vie de la
ménagère voilà et surtout vous fait un
sacré ménage en fait parce que on
s'aperçoit qu'on vit avec des idéaux su
qu'on nous inculque et je ne sais pas
d'où alors par exemple il ya eu la façon
de déguster la cuisine italienne alors
on se rajoutent des trucs autre mot
idiot enfin c'est vrai les choses comme
il y en avoir et qui servent à rien oui
les pattes des légendes des légendes
culinaire ben oui lattes moi ma maman
elle mettait toujours de l'huile dans
l'eau des pâtes bon alors vous tout le
monde a pu constater que l'huile remonte
donc lui il ne se mélangera jamais en
fait au pad donc ça n'a absolument pas
contribuer à éviter qu'elles collent en
revanche pour éviter qu'elles collent il
faut mettre suffisamment d'eau faut que
bouillon absolument de quantité bas où
on voit bien meilleur quand on met
beaucoup de pâtes dans une petite
casserole il ya un moment où ça fait une
espèce de deux parties et donc voilà ce
sont ce genre de choses qu'il faut
savoir remuer les pattes d'ef que sa
bonne écoute et que vous lui goûter
et puis voilà et puis par exemple le
risotto ne se sert jamais dans une
assiette creuse mais dans une assiette
plate sinon la cuisson sera pas la même
au dessus ou en dessous bon il ya plein
de petites choses comme ça sont pas de
savoir qu'ils sont bon à savoir pour
cuisiner d'une façon un peu plus
éclairés oui et alors du coup j'ai
l'impression moi je regardais les photos
bon y'a votre visage bien évidemment que
je regardais vos mains et j'ai
l'impression que vous avez un vrai
plaisir vous attraper le poisson veut
couper vous attrapez le foie gras en 101
plaisir vraiment à toucher la matière
mais ça vous plaît ça c'est vrai j'ai
beaucoup voyagé y compris avant de faire
la cuisine et notamment en asie et dans
des pays où on mange essentiellement
avec l'un déjà déjà et j'en ai tiré un
grand plaisir et donc non je me rends
socialise un peu embêté ar fire j'ai
quand même pas non plus manger ma
blanquette à la main quoique je suis pas
loin et du coup c'est vrai que j'ai
l'habitude alors bon on se lave les
mains évidemment surtout en ce moment
fait très attention mais c'est quand
même le meilleur outil je trouve bon pas
pour couper mais mais mais pour
effectivement manipuler pur pour sentir
sentir un degré de cuisson sentir une
température
oui c'est vrai que c'est assez spontané
ouais ça marche bien et puis ça marche
on prend un plaisir voilà et alors
contrairement aux idées reçues j'ai
l'impression que les chefs sont assez
généreux finalement parce que il n'a
beaucoup qui vous ont donné des astuces
alors on vous avait un charme fou
d'accord mais ils sont pas ils sont pas
si secret que ça finalement voilà j'ai
fait le siège de leur cuisine non mais
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer assez
vite moi j'ai commencé par la critique
gastronomique
donc j'ai rencontré alain ducasse voilà
qui est déjà vais pas dire qu'il
démarrait dans sa carrière mais il n'en
n'était pas là où il est aujourd'hui
michel guérard qui lui étaient déjà
consacrés mais qui est tellement
généreux d'une façon générale et puis
surtout sur la cuisine aprilia utile
marx avec qui j'ai fait des émissions
pierre hermé avec j'ai fait un livre
alain passard c'est le premier qui m'a
acceptée dans sa cuisine
j'étais prêt du tout connue je démarrais
à peine et je lui ai dit ma passion pour
la cuisine mais du bug de si vous avez
envie vous venez voilà la porte est
ouverte il n'a pas confié de tâches dans
tout cas trop difficile et l'a bien fait
mais il a eu la gentillesse de me
laisser en spectatrice de 5 à l'idée de
capter ces espions amine de 20 ans qui
se passionne pour la cuisine c'est
un grand merci julier merci alors je
vous encourage tout le monde à lire ce
livre à offrir ce livre c'est une bible
c'est une base et franchement ce père
ouais c'est hyper utile hyper agréable à
lire vont être vite peut-être sur le
marché ou dans les bras ou n'importe où
en train d'organiser une dédicace la dea
du bouquin est lui de retour et non à
l'orgue et on l'a déjà chez gibert
joseph fera des recherches dans les rues
et alors donc bon un gros merci merci
merci encore à la guinguette donc ce
sympathique restaurant là près du prés
du château là ils prêts à graver ses
jolies découvertes mais aussi brune
ouais alors viendra dingue à bientôt un
numéro unique
[Musique]